donc c'est la fin
frère bon livre nos vies demain
elle aura une chance du tout
elle aura besoin de plus de sang et tu as besoin de
te nourrir tu dois être à ton meilleur
pour elle nous devons y aller ce soir
Carlile tu es l'ennemi  maintenant Sam
n'hésitera pas tu seras massacré et ça
viendra avec nous ça ne suffira pas
nous n'avons pas le choix Jacob il y a tout ce que
nous pouvons faire pour le sauver nous devons essayer
tu risquerais ta vie pour elle bien sûr
nous  La caution fait partie de notre famille
maintenant
ouais
je peux voir que
c'est vraiment une famille
aussi forte que celle dans laquelle je suis né
Je sais ce que je dois faire
Jake ils arrivent Je sais que nous devrions
faire face à Jacob tu ne peux pas  protégez-
vous comme ça, ils le verront comme une menace Je
veux parler plus facilement si je peux vous entendre
aussi
donc vous n'êtes plus un territoire vous avez choisi
d'être un parasite rappelez-vous oui comment une
nouvelle famille travaille maintenant vous avez fait quoi  veux-
tu que je veuille que Sam reprenne le privilège
Seth ce qui n'est pas
calme
je veux qu'ils soient en sécurité et je veux que ça se termine
tu rentres à la maison Jake pas avant que j'aie fini
ça qu'est-ce que tu veux dire j'ai besoin que Sam attende
que Bella soit séparée du
problème signifie oh elle est morte mon amour Paul
qu'est-ce que tu dis à Sam que quand le moment viendra
je serai celui qui le détruira Jake je  Je suis
le seul à pouvoir
me faire confiance